SANDY LEGER: Hi, friends.
Thank you for coming here.
Thanks for wanting to listen
to us and learn about
prevention of human trafficking
in the US and abroad.
My name's Sandy Leger.
I am the co-founder, president,
and chairman of
abolishslavery.org.
And in a moment I'm going to
introduce Aaron Cohen here.
He's our speaker.
Human rights activist.
But before I do that, I want to
tell you a little bit about
our organization and the
movement to free slaves.
Slavery has changed
over the years.
It certainly wasn't abolished
150 years ago with the
Emancipation Proclamation
with Abe Lincoln.
As our president today says,
human trafficking is
modern-day slavery.
At Abolish Slavery, we work
to prevent the spread of
modern-day slavery by helping
establish and mentor human
trafficking task forces
domestically and
internationally.
That's a mouthful.
These task forces find and
protect human trafficking
victims and promote the
infrastructure needed to
rescue victims and assist them
on the road to recovery.
Today more than ever, victims of
human trafficking are being
prostituted, enslaved, abused,
tortured, and murdered by
predators who exploit their
vulnerabilities.
But with your help and with
the help of victim service
providers, we can free the
captives together.
The human trafficking movement
in the US is growing, and with
it, many organizations are
training law enforcement to
better understand the complex
dynamics of domestic
prostitution and sex
trafficking.
We recently completed a series
of investigations and rescues
in New York, working with the
NYPD, and vice detective Chris
Baughman from the Metro Las
Vegas Police Department and
certified shelters.
These partnerships were the glue
that kept us together,
and it led to the rescue
of several victims.
One of these victims is a young
lady named Christina.
She's from New Hampshire.
And I was there for all of
this, actually, as were
Melissa and Gracie,
my daughter.
She'd been trafficked all
throughout New Hampshire, all
the way down to New York.
And we rescued her-- it
was Abolish Slavery
with the NYPD help.
Her emotional reunion with her
mother was successful.
And she's now seeing a
counselor, she's applying to
colleges, and she has a blog
that you can visit at--
what's the name of it?
MELISSA GRACE HOON: It's on
coerciontofreedom.wordpress.com.
SANDY LEGER: Coerciontofreedo
m.wordpress.com.
MELISSA GRACE HOON: Correct.
SANDY LEGER: Great.
And her name's Christina.
With us today, speaking of,
is the victim advocate for
Abolish Slavery, Melissa
Grace Hoon.
Could you stand up?
MELISSA GRACE HOON: Hello.
SANDY LEGER: It's Melissa's
responsibility to coordinate
survivor transition and
security, as she did with our
survivor from New Hampshire,
so that post-rescue, our
survivors receive the best care
possible from the service
providers, and making sure that
their unique situations
are helped.
As of late, we've been
increasingly using technology
in our investigations and
finding sex trafficking
victims online.
We document them, and we're
allowed now to see something--
I think Aaron's going to say
later-- something that was
invisible, that we don't
normally know about, to
something that is visible.
For the last two years, Abolish
Slavery has trained
law enforcement in human
trafficking investigations in
Thailand, Cambodia, Indonesia,
Haiti, Mexico--
Ooh.
Wow, OK.
That's like being in a
department store when you see
yourself on the camera.
And also in the US, with
the FBI's help.
We plan to begin our
next round of
investigations next month.
We don't know exactly where
we're going to be, because we
had to change a plan.
The victims actually moved, the
traffickers moved them, so
it's not going to be where
we had intended in Texas.
But we continue to work with law
enforcement when we do the
investigations and the rescues
and transition the victims
from a life of slavery
to a life of freedom.
We just take it so
for granted.
We're also working on our next
installment of books and
television production.
We're excited to develop some
PSAs and other media to raise
awareness and to raise crucial
funds needed to continue the
work of bringing freedom
to those who are
lost in modern slavery.
It's my hope, and all of our
hope, that this short film
we're about to show you will
help explain the painstaking
work of rescuing victims who
at this very moment are
enslaved in the US.
AARON COHEN NARRATING: Human
trafficking is the
fastest-growing illegal
business.
It's already passed arms sales,
and it's in a position
to pass drug sales.
Ever since the internet boom,
sex trafficking has been
growing at an alarming rate.
The massage parlors of Asia are
teeming with young human
trafficking victims.
I met Na while working
undercover in Cambodia.
She told me she was 19,
but I could see
she was much younger.
AARON COHEN: What?
You're so shy.
We're moving into the
hot zone right now.
We're now literally
three buildings
away from the retrieval.
[MEN SHOUTING]
AARON COHEN NARRATING: I would
rank Cambodia as one of the
worst places for sex
trafficking.
AARON COHEN: So we're getting
ready for the SWAT guy to come
out of the station.
Basic estimates suggest that
there's up to 27 million
slaves in the world today.
Here in Haiti, there's
an unprecedented
300,000 domestic slaves.
I look and I see some
of the children
carrying in the street.
I can't help but feel as if
we're looking at modern-day
slavery here in Haiti.
AARON COHEN NARRATING: The
ancient land of Kush, known
today as Sudan, was connected
to Egypt by the Nile River.
Tradesmen and camel caravans
waged bloody civil wars for
the past centuries over the
natural resources, leaving
African tribal communities
destitute.
Heartbroken parents were facing
an agonizing choice
when they discovered that their
children had been taken
to this little-known place
called Darfur.
It was a long, difficult journey
for the former slaves
to walk home hundreds of
miles across the front
lines of a civil war.
MALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
AARON COHEN: Silence.
But I think they're starting to
figure out what's happening.
MALE SPEAKER: So nobody
should be afraid.
It's going to be a good day.
It's a happy day.
And that very soon, you'll all
be able to go back to your
homes and to find your mothers
and fathers and your husbands
and other relatives
and friends.
[SHOUTING]
AARON COHEN: This
is the children.
They are running off here to be
reunited with their families.
They're very excited.
[SHOUTING AND LAUGHTER]
AARON COHEN: They're
very happy.
Families are being reunited.
These are the children that
were just released.
There's pandemonium breaking
out as they hug each other
that they're free.
All of them have been abused
and have suffered many
terrible things.
They're very excited.
You see joy breaking
out everywhere.
AARON COHEN: Today's
your day, man.
MALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
AARON COHEN: Right?
Right.
Hey, buddy, let me hold
this stuff for you.
AARON COHEN NARRATING: When
Arason's mother unwittingly
turned him over to his aunt, he
was brokered into domestic
slavery, forced to work 14 hours
a day and beaten if he
do not obey.
He hadn't seen his mother
in more than 10 years.
So at the age of 12, Arason
returned home and was reunited
with his mother.
[SHOUTING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
AARON COHEN NARRATING: This
is a serious business.
It is very dangerous
to do this work.
Hello, hello.
[SHOUTING]
AARON COHEN: It's OK, it's OK.
It came back from the Human
Trafficking division that she
was a legal adult, that the
documents were in order.
The tape says it all.
The truth is the truth.
And no matter how hard you take
the truth and try to make
it something else, it's
still the truth.
They're not always
happy endings.
Right in there is
our little girl.
Right now, the girls are
probably still sleeping.
You can help some people, but
inevitably, the one you leave
behind becomes so much more
prominent in your mind than
the ones that you can help.
And that's something
I always live with.
I always live with the fact--
people say, well how many
children have you rescued?
Or how many slaves
have you freed?
And the answer is, how many have
I left behind, really?
And that haunts me.
It stays with me.
It never leaves.
SANDY LEGER: I've only watched
that a few times, and the boy
who was two years old when they
took him-- and I have a
two-year-old.
He can't even make real
sentences yet.
I can't even imagine.
OK, so it gives me great
pleasure to introduce to you
Aaron Cohen.
He's the mission director
for Abolish Slavery.
He's an award-winning--
I'll give you all the
goodies about him.
He's an award-winning writer and
human rights activist who
draws his inspiration from the
Jubilee, which is an ancient
law of debt forgiveness and
setting the slaves free.
Media, including FOX, CNN,
"Larry King Live," MSNBC, and
NBC, have a lauded Aaron's work
in finding and rescuing
victims of human trafficking.
He was awarded the US
Congressional Certificate of
Merit, the Prize for Humanity,
and the Major League
Baseball's Greatest Save
trophy for his efforts
combating slavery in the
United States and
in dozens of countries.
Working with the Abolish Slavery
team, Aaron trains
counter-human-trafficking task
forces and undercover police
officers in the US and
other countries.
His memoir, "Slave Hunter: One
Man's Global Quest to Free
Victims of Human Trafficking,"
has been translated into many
languages and will be available
at the book table
following our presentation.
Melissa and I and Gracie will
also be at the table, if any
of you are interested in making
a donation or asking us
about how you can be involved,
how you can help, and how you
can be part of setting
these slaves free.
So without further to-do,
I give you Aaron Cohen.
[APPLAUSE]
AARON COHEN: Thank you.
How is everybody today?
I'm so excited to be here and to
talk to you about slavery.
The original topic for the
discussion sort of germinated
when my friend Michael P. Hale
from Google and I were talking
about the use of technology
in saving lives.
And so we together came up with
this idea to sort of do a
little study, a little bit of
investigation about how the
role of technology is changing
both human trafficking
tremendously but also
human existence.
So if we're going to talk about
the role of technology
in saving lives, two things
need to be defined first.
First of all, we have to
define technology.
What is technology?
Where does it begin?
Who were the originators
of technology?
And secondly, we have
to define life.
How does life begin?
What is life?
So what was really interesting
for me is you know, I'm a
human rights activist and I
travel around the world,
working with vice detectives.
We work in task forces trying
to find victims of human
trafficking.
And it can be pretty
dry at times.
It's your typical scene,
drinking coffee and eating
doughnuts, and most of the
time, waiting around.
So I got really excited when
Michael talked to me about
putting this speech together,
because I learned a lot of
things studying about
technology.
Ultimately, we're trying, all
of us in this room, to take
our little--
our life--
and when I say "little life,"
I'm referring to myself.
And look at me.
I'm very oddly tall, right?
And am I in the Johnny
Cash Fan Club?
Maybe.
But the thing is that we're
trying to take our little
life, which is a drop, a little
stone in the water, and
our little waves come out to our
family and our friends and
to our outer circles.
How do we move that from
just a small impact
to something big?
And I realized that in looking
at technology and at life in
general, the answers
are there.
But what's so unique and so
different about this topic is
that the line between life and
technology is becoming more
and more blurred.
So when we talk about the
beginning of it, or an idea of
a Big Bang, I'm going to go
through a little bit of a
history of science with you.
We have these competing theories
on quantum physics,
the idea of string theory, where
mathematically, they put
together a 10-dimensional
reality.
And then you have another group
of physicists saying
they support this idea called
M-theory, which is really an
11-dimensionality that then
collides with the 10th to
create this Big Bang.
And what happens in a Big Bang
is that this explosion occurs,
this massive explosion, and then
like the little pebble in
the water, these huge cords of
universes and galaxies come
out from that big explosion.
And essentially, the oldest
writing we have in the world--
when I went to try to find the
origins of slavery, where
slavery begins--
the oldest writings in the world
are talking about the
cords of our galaxy.
And that's the cuneiform tablets
from ancient Sumeria.
They even name it.
They would look to Orion's belt
as sort of this Grand
Central Station that could take
them through the Pleiades
to the Northern Star, where all
the other stars rotated
around the Northern Star.
And there was this ancient
belief that somehow, the
domain of the heavens, or the
throne of the creator, shall
we say, was vested in this
northern position.
And so the cuneiform writings
talk largely about this.
They named the first cord
from the center Norma.
They named the second
cord Crux.
The third was called
Sagittarius.
And the fourth was
called Orion.
And that's where we live.
Our Milky Way galaxy is on the
fourth cord from the center of
our Milky Way galaxy, and we're
on planet Earth, the
third planet from the sun.
So when I realized that the
Sumerians, who in many ways
are the inventors of slavery,
because after all, the first
records of slavery come from
ancient Sumerian culture in a
place called Babylon.
Now, remember the Tower of Babel
from history lessons,
from the biblical story?
Ancient Babel was a place
where they all spoke one
common language.
They had a common theme.
And they had figured how to
become interconnected.
Now the word that they use in
the ancient Aramaic is this
word called "shem." Now a HaShem
or a shem is what we
call a name.
But that is not a good
translation for this word to
English, in my view.
As we look into the idea that
these people were building a
tower, the ancient tower
of Babylon--
this is the actual
historical ruins.
Saddam Hussein's palace
sat on that little
spiraling feature there.
And that was the actual ruins
of the Tower of Babel.
So it's a historical
archaeological site.
And what it says in the
scriptures, both biblical and
extrabiblical, is that they
built this tower so that they
could travel into the heavens
to build a name for
themselves.
So the word "shem," or name, in
the Hebrew is linked to an
idea of a codex, an idea of a
source coding that creates a
reaction in folks.
So that's essentially what
they're talking about when
they say a name--
a technology.
So all of a sudden, when
we think of technology,
technology is linked in the
ancient, ancient records to
the idea of a Big Bang and the
formation of life itself.
At the Tower of Babel, they
were very interconnected.
And so the idea that the
languages were confused, the
codes were confused-- remember
when Microsoft had their
security platform hacked
by the government?
How did it go?
The government said, you've got
too much of a monopoly.
We want to pull out your code.
So it confused the languages.
And it reminded me of this
important term called
emergence, which is the way
complex systems and patterns
arise out of multiplicity of
relative simple networks.
In other words, if you have a
complex problem to solve and
you have a colony of ants, a
single ant cannot solve the
complex problem.
But through emergence, through
emergence and through their
interconnectivity, a colony
of ants can solve very
intellectual complex problems
because of their collective
interconnectivity, their
collective intelligence.
So as we move forward to
discuss slavery and
technology, I think
that emergence is
an important concept.
Because after all, we've been
fighting slavery generation
after generation.
And it seems like every 100
years or so, we fool ourselves
by thinking somehow
we've done it.
But what happens is we don't
connect all the dots to
actually finish the job.
So today, there's more
slaves than any
time in human history.
They say that there's
upwards of 27
million slaves worldwide.
And if you think about that,
we're living in this
technology where we're all
connected, and yet at the same
time, the technology is being
used to lure, coerce, and
subjugate women and girls
into slavery.
There's a shot of the Tower of
Babel, which was an actual
thing that happened.
And what's cited as what was
the problem by the ancients
was the fact that they had
developed emergence.
They had developed
interconnectivity amongst
themselves so that no problem
that they sought to solve was
unsolvable.
They could literally
tap into eternity.
Their system was propagated
in Egypt.
In the legends of slavery, we
see that the god of Egypt,
which was Ra, the sun god, left
Egypt, became known as
Amun Ra, went to this historical
characters in
Babylon named Nimrod, and that's
where the Tower of
Babel was formed, from
the Amun Ra.
Of course, the story
picks up later
in the various histories.
But all the archaeological
ruins are there.
They would form shrines, and
from these shrines, they would
then recruit young women and
girls to work as shrine
prostitutes.
The men would oftentimes be
subjugated into labor and be
forced to build pyramids.
So we have the vestiges of
these communities and the
archaeological ruins of what
slavery produced in the past,
and they're still
with us today.
Unfortunately, I don't think
that we've answered the
questions as to why, as a single
human community, why as
a human single human community
would we subjugate each other
to slavery in order to pursue
these material objectives.
And of course, the Hanging
Gardens of Babylon are there
as a reminder to us.
As the science progressed, some
very, very interesting
people came on the scene.
Of course the founder of modern
science, Sir Isaac
Newton, he became famous, of
course, for the apple falling
onto his head, determining
gravity, of course.
But what he did is remarkable.
He was a student of the
ancient literatures.
So he would study mystical
traditions in literature.
And what he did was he took the
ratio of the Ark of the
Covenant, which was 1.5 cubits
by 2.5 cubits, and he created
a numerical factor which he
called the Sacred Proportion.
And he multiplied that
times pi times 360.
Then after him, another
scientist helped him to
develop, essentially, the
diameter of the Earth.
So the father of modern-day
science, Sir Isaac Newton,
with the help of Sir John
Watson, they were able to
determine the diameter
of the Earth.
And from that, there was a
curvature of the Earth that
was able to be determined, and
then they changed something.
They changed the measurement
of distance.
Using technology, they said
the kilometer, which was
distance over a straight line,
was not as accurate of a way
of measuring navigation on the
oceans, but rather distance
over the curvature of
the Earth was a
better way of going.
So today, if I travel to Japan,
or if I go to China, or
if I go to the Philippines or
to Indonesia, wherever I go,
English is almost a
second language.
And it's remarkable when
we think about that,
why that is the case.
Is it because of
our literature?
Is it because of our culture?
Is it because of
our democracy?
Well, it may have something to
do with the nautical mile, an
actual technological
advantage.
But of course, that technology
was used, those ships were
used to go and bring the African
slaves out of Africa
and bring them across into the
New Worlds to become enslaved.
And so what we've seen from the
ancient history, both from
Babylon to Egypt to today is
the use of technology to
empower a certain group of
people, but at the same time
to subjugate and put others
into a position of
vulnerability to that
technology.
Of course, after the initial
founders of modern science had
their run, a gentleman came
on the scene named Cantor.
And what Cantor did is he
reinvented, for all practical
purposes, mathematics.
Now we already had this
mathematics in some of our
ancient languages, related
to Chinese and Aramaic.
But what Cantor did is he said,
let's take a seed and
let's plant a seed.
And we'll say the
seed is a line.
And then the law of how that
seed divides is we take the
line and we divide
the line in half.
So in the first generation,
we plant the seed.
In the second generation, we
divide the line in half and
execute the law of growth.
Then those two become four,
those four become eight--
the bytes system was developing,
the idea of
utilizing zeros and ones in
low-level language to create
an operating system through
which interconnectivity and
intelligence could
be communicated.
So of course, what happened
to Cantor?
He went crazy and ended up
in an insane asylum.
But he inspired a group of
mathematicians, Fournier and
some others, who developed what
they called immortal math
or chaos theory.
The idea that 1 plus 1 equals
2 was a concept in what we
call mortal math.
But 1 plus 1 equals infinity
is reflected in this.
Because a seed is planted and
it divides to infinity.
So this is a different construct
of looking at
mathematics and physics that
Cantor and Fournier
developed for us.
And of course, those were the
seeds that led, of course, to
the computer coming
on the scene.
So here we are.
We're in the year 2013.
We have more slaves than
we've ever had in any
time in human history.
It's the fastest-growing
illegal business.
And the technology is on the
rise to both enslave the human
and to free the human.
And so I'm here today largely
to ask for your help.
Because gosh, these pimps and
these traffickers are
utilizing the internet and
Facebook and social networking
sites to find their victims.
And from there, what they do is
they recruit them using a
whole series of mechanisms,
and they then subject them
into slavery.
And the police and the law
enforcement task forces that
we work with at Abolish Slavery,
they're not as
tech-savvy, per se, as some of
the traffickers and pimps who
are out there preying on
young women and girls.
So what are we going to do?
How are we going to catch up
with the bad guys in this
particular issue?
For me, I had this experience
where early on in the human
trafficking movement,
I became a vice
detective looking for victims.
So I was the guy who was
the undercover person.
I would pose as a john.
I would go into brothels, and
I would essentially try to
interview a victim to find out
if they were a victim of sex
trafficking.
Generally speaking, I would
look for the youngest ones
that I could find.
And I would wear a wire, because
I needed a technology
to actually document
the crime.
But the problem was that
the wire was so--
I had a transponder, and the
wire went from my shirt, not
unlike the microphone
I'm wearing now.
It went from a shirt to here,
and then I had to have a
backpack to pick
up the signal.
And I used to get such anxiety
over the wire.
I would come into my hotel room
and it'd be sitting there
on the counter, and my heart
would start racing.
Oh my gosh, the wire.
I would get very, very nervous
that somehow I would get
caught wearing the wire and
something bad would happen.
And so I began to project from
that thinking, I began to
project fear onto the device.
And what I had done was I had
put a reminder of fear in
front of myself, and it began to
inhibit my ability to work
with the victim in the room.
And what I do when I enter that
room is I'm trying to get
to know the person and
win their trust.
But if I'm afraid, if I'm filled
with doubt, how am I
going to do that?
It's very difficult to win
someone's trust if you're
doubtful and you're fearing.
And I meditated on it.
I thought to myself, you know,
I've got to put the wire away.
I cannot work with the wire and
have it out and see it and
have my heart started beating
as a reaction, almost like a
Pavlov's dog reaction.
I ring the bell and the dog
would think dinner's coming.
Well, I would see the wire and
I would become fearful.
And what I realized is that I
needed to keep the vision of
what I was trying to do in front
of me, not the fear.
So I had put a vision of
something that created fear
and doubt in front of me, and it
was affecting the way that
I performed in my job.
So what I did instead
is I looked for an
alternative to the wire.
And it's interesting--
you laugh about it, but these
birds, says it's a bit freaky
with the wireless technology.
They're just hanging on nothing
there in the air.
And that's what I
was looking for.
I was looking to become the
person that could work in that
room with the victims in a way
where I wouldn't be caught
wearing a wire and get
beat up or worse.
So as time went on, I realized
I needed to put something in
front of me.
I needed to keep my vision
in front of me.
And what I began to do is I
looked at the wire, and
instead of having the
wire there, I
replaced it with a key.
And I put a key there on the
counter in front of me.
And that made a huge
difference for me.
Because when I would walk by and
see my keys there, all of
a sudden, I would realize, oh,
yeah, I put the keys there,
because the wire was
there before.
And the key is this thing that
will unlock these victims from
being enslaved.
Even myself--
I can unlock my own issues,
my own problems.
Because I was doubting myself.
I thought, why should I be
the guy to be doing this?
How did I end up here?
How could I possibly
sustain this?
It's so expensive.
All of these doubts and things
arised in my mind that
probably could have changed
my path so that I
wouldn't have continued.
But I began to realize that not
only was the technology
this great macro Big-Bang
phenomenon, but the technology
was also this micro thing
inside of me.
It was a micro/macro situation,
where both my life
and the technology and the
application of them to freedom
for others was something very
relevant to what was going on
in my life.
I discovered Dr. Masaru Emoto.
Now he's a very controversial
figure in the scientific
community, because he developed
a theory which sort
of lends itself to what I'm
talking about right now.
His idea was to take water,
dirty water from a dam, bring
in a group of folks who could
meditate over the water, and
then measure the molecules and
take pictures of the water
crystals prior to the meditation
and then following
the meditation.
And he discovered some
shocking things.
And if you look on the figure,
it shows the water from the
dam, and then it shows the water
from the dam after the
offering of a prayer.
And he essentially photographed
water by putting
love one water, thank you.
And he began to notice that
whatever the messaging was,
whatever the consciousness of
the people who were meditating
over that water had, it
affected the molecular
structure of the water.
So he reduplicated
the experiment
over and over again.
He was criticized by the
scientific community for going
straight to the public and not
debating this further in the
scientific community.
But whether or not you buy into
his theories or not, the
idea that our conscious thoughts
affect us not only on
a molecular level within
ourselves but the
people around us.
And what I began to realize was
that I was talking myself
out of successfully rescuing
girls out of this life.
And what I was talking myself
into by projecting fear, by
projecting doubt, I was
literally manifesting that.
I was manifesting getting
caught wearing a wire.
And it's a very dramatic
scene.
They rip the wire from you, and
then they smash it, and
then the next thing
you know, there's
three guys at the door.
And your hair, and this and
that, and do I fight back?
And so all of that was something
that I was able to
actually manifest through
my fear of it.
And I had to change
my thinking.
So when I found the water
molecule study, I realized
that if I create positive
affirmations for myself, if I
have a can-do attitude instead
of a "oh my gosh, what will
happen if that happens?"
attitude, I needed people to
speak favor over me.
I was out there maybe a little
bit too much on my own, and I
began to doubt and fear.
Another analogy that helped
me was the idea that I had
reached a point where I was
crawling in this movement.
I couldn't raise the funding.
If I rescued a victim, I could
barely take care of that one
particular person.
I needed wings to fly.
I needed to find out a way to
move from my caterpillar
position into a position of
becoming a butterfly.
And I did that by going to
graduate school and studying
the subject of the Jubilee.
Now Jubilee was this ancient
musician who lived way back in
ancient Sumeria nearly
5,000 years ago.
He's called the father
of all musicians.
But today, we still call a good
party after his name.
We still use his
name, Jubilee.
The queen has a 50-year
anniversary.
It's the Jubilee.
So I went to graduate school.
I studied the agent law of the
Jubilee, which was found not
only in biblical tradition
but in all the peripheral
traditions.
Because the musician Jubilee
himself was so ancient that we
find Jubilee in Tibetan
Buddhism.
We find Jubilee in Christianity
and Islam.
It's in Judaism.
It's in Hinduism.
It's found cross-platform
amongst all societies.
So I essentially
wrote a thesis.
I wrote a book.
I had a dream.
And instead of approaching my
dream with fear, I began to
put my vision in front of me.
I had these little circles that
had chains broken, and
I'd put it up over my bed.
And I'd wake up in the morning
and I would see there the
broken chains.
And I would think to myself,
I'm going to do it.
I would speak favor
over myself.
At the time, I was working with
a rock band, and I found
some incredible musicians
who would help me.
And we traveled to
the G8 summits.
We asked all the other musicians
we could find to
sign petitions, and we set the
world record the biggest
petition ever created.
It was millions and millions
of signatures.
And we submitted it at the G8
summit in 1999 to Bill Clinton
and the political leaders to
drop Third World debt.
And it was a huge success.
So I had taken a few of the
little principles that I had,
which was positive
affirmations--
but not just positive
affirmations.
Changing my mindset.
It's one thing to have
a positive mentality.
It's another thing to say, I'm
going to be transformed by
renewing my mind.
So I began to try to think
of ways that I
could renew my thinking.
The campaign was
a huge success.
Bono took the lead.
Perry Farrell and Bob Geldof
were big supporters.
We raised a lot of money
and we parlayed that.
Now the Jubilee was forgiving
debts and freeing slaves, and
I wanted to try to manifest
this in my life.
So I sought out to first
forgive debts.
And we forgave Third
World debt.
We're still working today with
Rolling Jubilee that is an
organization that works to
relieve medical debt for
people who have fallen
into poverty.
But the Jubilee was a
two-pronged thing-- forgiving
debts and also freeing slaves.
In 1997, when I was working with
Michael P. Hale, I didn't
even know where slavery
existed.
I just knew that theoretically,
it was
something that I wanted to talk
about, the idea of being
enslaved to myself, my own
thinking, or my ability to
transform from that caterpillar
position to a
butterfly and renew my mind.
So what did we do?
We went online.
We used technology to find out
where there were slaves.
So I essentially went into a
search engine and then I typed
in slavery, and I began looking
at a few links, and I
saw that there was
slavery in Sudan.
So after we created a concert
tour, we did some festivals,
we raised some money, and the
next think you know, I was on
a plane on my way to this
country, Sudan.
Flying over the Nile River.
Crossing the border of Kenya
into Sudan, there's this city
called Lokichogio, and it's
sort of their last outpost
before you're going all the
way inside, where there's
really no more hospitals,
there's no more
infrastructure, no more
Coca-Cola, no
more bottled water.
It's ceramic water filters
after this point.
We land.
The local military greets us.
And at the time, I didn't really
know what I was getting
myself into.
I just knew that I wanted to be
involved in freeing slaves.
And so we land and the reality
hadn't really hit me yet.
I was sort living--
it was kind of like "The Lion
King." The trees were similar.
There was drum music playing.
And I romanticized Africa so
much that when I landed, it
hadn't really hit me what
was about to happen.
So we're landing, the plane is
there, and they begin loading
bodies into body bags to move
them on trucks out of the
region, because the civil war
between the north and south
was very bloody.
And the Janjaweed, these
raiders, were being supported
by this group nobody had ever
heard of called al-Qaeda.
And al-Qaeda was there, and
they were then looking to
subjugate people into slavery
to promote the well-being of
some of their sponsors.
So we would unload the survival
kits and deal with
the murahaleen.
We called them the Schindlers
of the Taliban.
They were these humanitarian
Muslim guys who had helped to
devise an Underground Railroad
in Sudan, bringing the victims
out from the north, from
this place no one
had ever heard of--
Darfur.
The slaves come out.
You start to put a face on
slavery and to realize that a
slave is not the same
as a free person.
A free person is responsible
for all their decisions.
Somebody who's a victim of
slavery, they have very little
responsibility in their life.
And so when you begin to see
this humble spirit--
my first encounter with slaves
was really shocking, because
they would just look down and
then they wouldn't give eye
contact, and they would
just answer yes or no.
They were very, very
submissive.
Some of the children that we
encountered in the camps had
nothing at all.
They had come back through the
Underground Railroad, and
along the way, someone saw
shorts or a shirt, would take
it from them.
But ultimately, reuniting them
with their families after that
arduous journey was an
incredible moment of my life.
I realized something about
myself, that whatever dreams
and goals that I had had before,
of having this big
music festival or doing
these things,
those dreams were fine.
But the idea of liberating
people had superseded all my
other plans.
And it became sort of my master
dream for my life, the
ability to take what I've been
given, the education that I'm
learning, and to try to use it
instead of, per se, pursuing
material things on my own, but
to help liberate others.
I was a Forrest Gump.
I was in the right place at
the right time when some
things were happening.
I had hundreds and hundreds of
hours of interviews of slaves.
And so we took our package to
the US government, and they
passed a law called the
Trafficking Victim Protection
Act of 2000.
This was a big milestone.
Because like the Emancipation
Proclamation, the Trafficking
Victim Protection Act empowered
law enforcement by
providing nearly $500,000 of
funding for every single
jurisdiction.
A lot of the contracts
went to me.
And as I approached the work--
I first went to Nicaragua--
I had always been doing
slavery sort of
intellectually.
I was looking at the different
organizations.
I was seeing how they worked
in task forces.
This one's good at shelters.
This one's good at
investigations.
This one's good at psychological
help.
And I was completely analyzing
everything all the time.
But when I began to get the
contracts to do the
investigation in sex trafficking
assessments,
that's when I had to really,
really work on my mindset.
Because fear could easily
creep back in.
How many of us say, I
can't do that job?
I can't get that promotion.
I can't be in this
relationship.
I can't do this.
I can't do that.
I had to change my mindset in
order to be able to do the
investigations.
So largely, that meant changing
my environment.
Because in order for me to keep
a positive mindset, I had
to have a team around me.
And I have a great team.
And by changing my environment
and getting into an
environment that was going to
speak favor over my life, I
was able to change my mindset
properly and then begin the
process of essentially becoming
a vice agent in sex
trafficking investigations.
I was in Miami and I met
somebody who would become a
little bit of a mentor for
me and inspire me.
I don't know if you recognize
her picture, but her name is
Cedella Booker.
And she's a very
famous mother.
She's the mother
of Bob Marley.
And so I was friends with her
godson, and we went to visit
her one day.
And she pulled out her Bible
and began studying and was
very interested in slavery,
knew that I was working in
Sudan trying to free slaves.
And we began a little study, and
I showed her the Tower of
Babel, and I showed her the
movement to free slaves in the
ancient world under the
prophet Elijah.
And we talked about the
different historical
characters who had played
a huge role.
And she brought up Haile
Selassie, whose famous line,
"Emancipate yourselves
from mental slavery.
None but ourselves can free
our minds." And all of a
sudden, the idea that it's much
different than a positive
mindset to free your mind.
To free your mind
is a different
thing than being positive.
It means transforming the way
you're thinking, and no longer
conforming any longer to the
pattern of the world.
Because the pattern
of the world
puts us into our cubicle.
It puts us into our position,
and it tells us, you do this
job, and that's your identity.
So to get beyond that, Mama B
basically said to me, you
should write your memoir.
If you think about what happened
with Bob Marley, she
had a situation with Bob Marley
where here's this young
man, he's living in
a place where
there's a lot of poverty.
There's not a lot of opportunity
to travel or do
much there.
But what she did was speak
favor over his life.
You can do it.
You can change the world
from right here.
It begins with yourself.
And she was so proud to talk
about how her and her son
spent a lot of time growing
up, and how he was very
inspired by the whole
idea of freedom.
And that freedom for himself,
for his people, for his
country, for the world, was
a huge ideal for him.
So after an hour of inspiring
session with Mama B, I left.
And a little while later,
the phone rang.
She had invited me back that
weekend for another study.
I said, sure, yeah.
I'll study with Bob
Marley's mom.
[LAUGHS]
And so I went back to the house
and she had this book.
And the book had been translated
into Hebrew.
And it was her memoir.
It was her life story.
And she wanted to give
me the book.
And she basically said to me,
you need to write your story.
You need to write your story.
She spoke favor over my life.
And that inspiration, for me,
helped me realize that if I'm
going to change my little ripple
into a Big Bang, I'm
going to need to use
technology to
get my story out.
And I'm going to need to use
technology to take on
organized crime.
And I'm going to need to use
technology on myself
biologically to change my mind,
to change my thinking.
Because I'm scared.
I'm afraid.
I don't know if any of you
have ever looked down the
barrel of a gun, but it changes
the way that you
think, because you realize
how much of life
we're taking for granted.
And so I did it.
I wrote the book.
From that point on, I began to
really work on myself in the
context of the investigation.
So I went at it with
a vengeance.
I was traveling 80% of the time
on one contract or the
other, for one organization
or another.
Working in Cambodia, I would
work in the karaoke brothels,
singing karaoke to basically
children in the brothels.
We would find a victim
in there.
We would ask her to go get
all of her young friends.
They would all be rescued
by the police.
Maybe a year or two later,
I would go back and be
reunited with them.
Very proud moment, the
day that Jonty
graduated from high school.
We had rescued her when
she was 13 years old.
So when she was 17 and graduated
from high school,
they invited me to come
present her diploma.
So I went and I presented Jonty
and the other girls
their diplomas.
And I began to realize
that you know what?
I'm just one person.
And as one person, I could have
an impact on the people
around me, the people that I
love, my family and friends.
Gracie's here, and Melissa's
here, and Sandy, and Michael--
these are people that I've known
for a long time and who
I love, that speak favor
over my life.
If I didn't have that, I
didn't have the right
environment, I don't know if I
could have reached the point
emotionally and psychologically.
Even today as I'm preparing
for the missions that are
coming up, I'm going to be in
that room again, wearing the
microphone.
The rooms are fully camera'd.
But I have to essentially
work on myself first.
And by renewing my mind, I
then prepare myself, my
vessel, to become a conduit,
to be able to take a power
greater than me and put it
through me into the work.
And that may sound funny, but
a lot of people, they sit at
their cubicle or they sit at
their desk, and they think,
this is just my job,
what I have to do.
But I think that if you can
get beyond that kind of
thinking and start thinking that
this is just a conduit,
this is a vessel for me to
channel a lot more through my
life, it's very transformative.
Travelled to Iraq, worked on
the slavery problem on the
border between Syria and Iraq.
Very difficult situation
there today.
Traveled to Burma.
Doing human trafficking work, we
run into an entire village
of people who are starving to
death because they're cut off
from the war.
I call Sandy.
Sandy, can you help out?
We have a situation and the
whole village is starving.
So what does Sandy do?
She buys truckloads of rice and
olive oil and milk powder.
And we organize a convoy, we
risk it all, and we get the
village fed.
Just problem-solving along the
way in Haiti, after the
earthquake.
You saw from the video, the
young boys that were carrying
cement after the earthquake,
and going
around with a SWAT team.
You know, the prison collapsed,
and all the pirates
in the Caribbean who were in
jail got out in a single day.
And they went to this one place,
Cite Soleil, the city
of the sun, and they began
buying arms from UN traders.
And next thing you know, every
day we go in, there's these
exchanges going on.
But here's these little kids
carrying cement blocks.
And it's remarkable, when
you think about it.
What both sides are struggling
to do is get better
technology.
The prisoners who had escaped
were looking for the best
technology in weapons.
The guards that are the SWAT
guys who we're working with
are asking us, can you
get us night vision?
Can you get us this?
Everybody's trying to scramble
to get the technology.
But in a way, I see it
as the Dark Ages.
Because we're scrambling to
get the technology to go
against each other.
When are we going to be
scrambling to get the
technology to create the unity
and the holistic life that as
a human family we could
actually appreciate?
We arrested a bunch of suspects,
took them to jail.
And then we had the privilege
of reuniting these children
with their families.
And I don't know if you know,
but the gasp for breath when
they hug each other--
recently, we had this reunion in
New York, a young gal from
our operation--
I think that Sandy
mentioned her.
We call her Veronica.
But Veronica was in a
very dire situation.
And when she was brought to
her mother, when they
embraced, that gasp for air--
oh, you'll see it.
We filmed the whole thing.
Same thing with young Arason.
I'm still involved
in Arason's life.
Early Last year, we got him
a bike and a cell phone.
He's playing soccer.
Has a hurt leg from
carrying bricks.
His foot's hurt somehow, but
he's moving on his life.
We always think of slavery
over there
from the ancient world.
We think of slavery, we're
thinking Cambodia, Haiti.
But did you know that the
greatest demand for slavery in
the world is in the
United States?
It's the demand for slavery that
fuels the slave market.
Who needs the slaves the most,
in terms of their economy?
It's us.
We have an entire generation
of men who are learning
sexuality on the internet, which
is much different than
how it was 15, 20 years ago.
So nowadays when an
eight-year-old boy follows a
link in his email to something
he shouldn't be watching, it
changes his sexuality.
It changes him.
It's not the favor that's being
spoken over him, that we
were talking about earlier.
So what we've done is we began
to try to use technology the
way that the traffickers are.
So I've spent the whole
winter in New York.
And this is a picture
of our control room.
You can see me there in
the room, waiting
for the girl to arrive.
I went on Backpage,
and I worked
with Detective Baughman.
And the detective, he's an ace
at saying, this language, this
ad, it looks like it's
written by a pimp.
And I think we should
put her on the list.
So the next thing you know,
we've a list of 30, 40 girls
that we're going to call.
And then I call them, and
we arrange a date.
The girl comes to
the hotel room.
I'm in one room.
I've got the police
and security guys
in the other room.
And the room is wired,
I mean wired.
And very hot, because there's
all these big
police guys in there.
And the stakes are
really high.
It's illegal to solicit
sex in our country.
So if I say the wrong thing to
a question, if I make a wrong
response, I could be arrested,
or what we're doing could be
shut down by the police.
So I'm walking this
tightrope of
explaining to the girl that--
I create a mess on the bed.
I create a flow so that she
goes straight to the room
service table.
I have staged a salad
that's been barely
eaten, and I'm hungry.
And I'm ordering room service.
So that we flow from the date,
from the encounter, into the
room service table.
And then I began to ask them
questions about their life,
and I begin to share my
challenges in my experiences
with their life.
And I'm think in my mind, if I
can create emergence with this
person, with others, if I can
connect her to Melissa, if I
can connect her to Sandy, I
began to visualize in my mind
to keep my vision in front of
me with the victim there.
And largely in the first
encounter, I listen and try to
develop trust.
I'll cut off the date right at
the hour, and I won't tip her.
If it's $200 an hour, $300 an
hour, or $400 and hour, I just
give exactly that.
But I'm taking notes
the whole time.
Is she on her cell phone?
Is she texting?
What is she doing?
You know, what the pimps do--
when the girl walks in the room,
she's required in the
first three minutes to
text, I'm OK, to say
what's going on.
Then every three to five
minutes, they're checking in.
And you know why?
Because 80% of prostituted women
have violence done on
them by johns.
So the women are scared.
A lot of them are shaking
and nervous in the room.
I try to make them feel at ease,
warm into the situation,
get to know them, talk to them
about my challenges, have them
talk to me about their
challenges.
I may even project a false
avatar on the young lady.
I may say, oh, you're doing this
because you love sex and
you're probably going
to meet some Prince
Charming doing this work.
No, not at all.
I mean, other people chose
this bag for me,
other people did this.
And by projecting a false
avatar, there's interrogative
techniques that we can use.
If you speak favor on somebody
and it's what they want to
hear, they'll say yes.
If you take something else,
a false identity, and you
project it on them, they
will then correct it.
When she begins to correct
it, that's the
beginning of the interview.
From there, we can determine
if she's a victim or not.
And if she's a victim, then we
collect the evidence with the
cameras we have.
And we're using, largely,
HD cameras.
But I'm no longer wearing
the wire.
Finally, my cellphone has
reached a point where I have
high definition on my cell.
I have my partner, Detective
Baughman, in the next room,
and he's texting me just like
the girl's being text.
He's my lifeline.
She may go the bathroom
and he'll say,
she's in the bathroom.
Don't turn your back.
So I have to turn around to make
sure that I never have my
back to the victim.
Because I could be stabbed.
Something bad could happen,
god forbid.
So I'm keeping my key on the
counter in front of me.
I'm keeping the mindset
in front of me.
I'm thinking to myself
positive thoughts.
I'm projecting the renewing
of my mind on this person.
We're talking about deep
philosophical things-- about
freedom, about slavery, about
the use of her phone.
Technology has become this
intimate companion in the
human trafficking
investigation.
And unfortunately, I'm here to
tell you that the pimps and
the traffickers are ahead
of the rescuers.
They're ahead of us
technologically.
They've found a way to use
anonymity and denial.
The technology has afforded
them, through the use of the
internet, to create anonymity
and denial amongst the johns.
And there's more johns in the
United States than there are
in any country in the world,
because we have the biggest
middle-class economy, and
there's more men willing to
buy sex in our country.
The problem is there are not
enough women willing to
satisfy the demand.
So what happens when
that happens?
What happens is the market
says, OK, let's
make it more expensive.
And so what happens is that
human trafficking networks
need to lure, coerce, corral,
and subjugate young girls into
trafficking.
And they do it on Facebook.
They do it on Instagram.
They do it on all the
popular platforms.
The thing is that I was excited
to speak at Google
because of all the companies
that I've seen-- and there's a
lot of companies out there that
have issues with slavery.
All of us as Americans, we have
issues of slavery because
of a lot of our products.
Whether they're T-shirts or
tomatoes or chocolate or
whatever it is, slavery is
reaching its little fingers
everywhere in our
lives right now.
But the thing about Google is
that they're investing in the
intelligentsia.
A couple of my friends who have
PhDs in human trafficking
are working with Google to
look for solutions in
technology.
There's some guys at USC who are
working on technology and
human trafficking to find ways
for us to utilize the
technology to identify the
victims and to rescue them.
So if you look at the set-up
in New York, we've got some
sophisticated stuff.
But so do the traffickers.
So do the pimps.
This is a shot of Detective
Baughman, my partner.
He's watching me in the other
room, and one of the
cameras is on him.
And he's taking notes on every
single detail that occurs.
So you know, when I look out
here, I'm not looking at
regular people.
You are not regular folks.
I'm looking at royalty here.
You are royalty.
You live in an economy.
You have an intellect.
You work at one of the top
companies in the world.
I'm looking at geniuses here--
geniuses who can change
the world.
It just takes getting
up off the chair,
renewing your mindset.
But I really believe that if you
get out of the habit like
I was, of saying, I can't rescue
that victim, I can't
get legislation to happen, I
can't get out of this contract
with this nonprofit
organization.
I can't--
and you start saying to
yourself, I can invent that
new technology.
I can go upwards
in my company.
I can reinvent myself.
I can do better in that
relationship.
I think it's our ability to
speak favor over each other
and our ability to renew
our mind, that's where
the freedom is that.
The more I get involved in the
issues of slavery, the more I
realized how enslaved I am to
my own addictions, to my own
old ways of thinking.
So in closing, I want to inspire
you to think about not
just positivity, not just
thinking positively, but
actually renewing your mind,
catching yourself
in moments of doubt.
I'm just one person.
I'm a guy who thought he could
somehow learn about slavery.
From there, I became someone
who thought, hey, maybe I
could actually get involved
in the fieldwork.
So I went from studying it
intellectually to then getting
involved in the fieldwork.
And then from there, I realized,
gosh, I'm just this
small fish in a big pond, and
I'm in Sudan, and how am I
going to change my little ripple
into something bigger?
Into a Big Bang?
And the answer is technology.
Technology with myself on the
micro level, the way I affect
the molecular structure of the
water in my body through
speaking favor over my life,
but also changing the world
outside of me with speaking
favor over others, with the
mentality of renewing
the mind.
With the use of technology
to create emergence.
Emergence.
Because by yourself, by myself,
I can't do this work.
I need Sandy.
I need Melissa.
I need Michael.
It's our emergence
that's going to
create an end to slavery.
We will continue to free
captives through our
interconnectedness.
And so I want to thank you for
listening today, and I want to
encourage you to think about how
you can utilize technology
to create a greater sense of
emergence in your life.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Can you discuss
the extent of
the problem for boys?
AARON COHEN: It's
a good question.
It's interesting how our society
almost condones the
exploitation of women
and girls.
Because when you see a very
young girl at a club, people
don't think twice about it.
But when you go looking for
young boys, they're so hidden
away that you've really
got to be seeking and
finding to get it.
You've got to actually
know that's what
you're going after.
I've worked on some
investigations
regarding young boys.
And generally speaking, they
will take a young boy and they
will put him into a strip club
or a brothel situation.
And then he's there cleaning,
or whatnot.
And then customers will come
in and someone will see and
say, you know.
So it's similar with boys
and girls, the way
they utilize them.
But they represent
a much smaller
demographic than women.
Of all the 27 million
slaves worldwide,
upwards of 80% are females--
and young females.
So it is a problem with boys.
It's a much more recondite
problem.
It's hidden from everybody
and it's very
difficult to find it.
It's difficult to find it from
an investigative perspective.
You can find it online,
no mistake about it.
The will amongst society to do
something about it is not the
same thing as with women.
We're both accepting of the
slavery of women in our
society and we almost put
the boy issue away.
Now from the law enforcement
perspective, there's people
doing something about it.
I'm glad that they are.
I've worked on some assignments
myself.
It's more difficult, and
more needs to be done.
However, I think it's good
that we talk about human
trafficking and slavery in
the context of women
predominantly.
Because after all, they make up
the vast, vast majority of
victims who are being
exploited.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering how
closely you work with some of
these technology companies whose
products are being used
to sort of perpetuate
this worldwide.
Do you help them monitor or
watch out for this on their
systems, or train people within
these companies to
watch out for it and escalate
it appropriately?
AARON COHEN: Well, the question
regarding whether or
not we work with the companies
that have the issue, it's
always a sort of a--
you can have an adversarial
relationship or a cooperative
relationship.
And in the case of Craigslist,
we had an adversarial
relationship.
Because you know, you go to
these people, you say, little
boys and little girls are being
sold on your web page
and lives are being lost.
Here's a whole list
of the victims.
Here's a list of the
ones that died.
Here's a list of the ones who
are recovering, that were sold
on your service.
And there's no return call.
There's nothing.
And then there's some brazen
remark about how we can't
police the internet.
We're in favor of
net neutrality.
So what happens is when people
are making a lot of money on
something--
we had a similar problem
with Backpage.
Because Backpage, Village Voice
Media, Backpage owned
Village Voice Media.
So we organized some protests,
and we went down there and
protested at Village Voice
headquarters in New York, and
made a passionate plea.
And what happened was that
the company sold
off its Village Voice--
it's almost like a mob
operation, where the mob would
have a restaurant and they
"own" the restaurant.
There's never any customers
there, but they
have meetings there.
And then what happens is you
find out, OK, this is your
restaurant.
Then what they do is they sell
the restaurant and move
somewhere else.
So in a sense, that's
what happened in
the Backpage analogy.
In terms of tech companies
that we're working with,
there's some great products
that Google has coming out
that I'm excited about.
A lot of the cloud services
and the ability to network
with people and have video
conferencing are huge
components for us.
If we could have greater access
to video chat, that
would be a huge thing.
The other thing is cameras.
We need to find a tech company
that can make a smaller
smaller type of audio-recording
device.
We have memory so small.
Wouldn't it make sense to make a
microphone really small that
could grab all the
audio properly?
Because the audio becomes key
with law enforcement and
getting the warrant to
rescue the victim.
But we have cell phone
technologies which have
advanced tremendously.
And in New York, the New York
Police Department, they
subpoenaed my video and my audio
recordings from one of
our investigations.
The pimp was beating her up
and was caught on camera.
The use of technology from the
street corner gets her
getting beat up.
He goes into jail, and then
he gets out of jail.
And I'm on the way to her, to
try to get to her at the
shelter, but he gets
to her first.
If we had the right kind of
technology, communication set
up between the shelters, we
would have been able to
intercede on that
victim's behalf.
So most of the relationship with
tech companies has been
to show the problem online,
whether it was
Craiglist or Backpage.
But in terms of companies that
are making products that are
functional in the
investigation--
of course Apple and Google.
And I would like to see them
take a bigger role not just in
discussing this subject
intellectually or funding more
studies, but actually developing
technologies that
will enable us to camera a room
and get audio and video
in a way where it doesn't
require an entire army of
wires and components
in the next room.
We're still in the Dark Ages,
a little bit, on the
technology.
And I know that the
technology exists.
So I don't have a sponsorship
with a tech company.
I've worked against a number
of the platforms that the
victims are being sold on.
And I've seen other companies
step forward
and start doing things.
For example, Hersey,
there was an issue
with chocolate slavery.
But they're starting to look at
ways to utilize technology
in the Ivory Coast and in Ghana
to better monitor what's
going on on the thousands of
farms and whatnot, to sort of
try to intervene.
So I think that the traffickers
are ahead of the
tech companies, because they
get the products first and
begin utilizing them before the
tech companies have them
in the hands of the human
rights activists.
[APPLAUSE]